ils sont heureux les collégiens d'amiral
Bouvet à Saint-Benoît ces jeunes ont en
effet de quoi être fier puisqu'ils ont
raflé pas moins de deux récompenses lors
des sixième rencontre et correspondables
de bras pas non ils ont été couronnés
par un premier prix dans la catégorie
collège qui s'accompagne du Trophée de
ses rencontres et correspondables l'idée
par est simple mais a su fait des réel
faire naître de vraies passions au sein
du collège allons donc parcourir le
sentier botanique du collège amiral
pierre-bouvet
heureux végétaliser la course
c'est-à-dire donner plus d'importance
aux espaces verts dans la cour pour
apporter de la sérénité au collège et
aussi de la fierté d'appartenance pour
que les élèves soient fiers de leur
collège qu'ils le trouvent beau qu'ils
en soi fiers qu'ils aient envie de venir
et donc dans cette revégétalisation on a
on place on met en place un sentier
botanique donc ce sentier botanique
dans ce sentier botanique on met on met
en place quatre types de plantes on a
les plantes endémiques et indigènes de
la Réunion
les plantes médicinales et les plantes
exotiques qui servent d'ornementation
un jardin qui existe depuis maintenant 4
ans mais qui grâce au conseil général
c'est littéralement embellit ces
derniers mois ce projet de
bio et puis il a pris son envol l'année
dernière avec le concours du plus beau
collège fleuri organisé par le Conseil
Général et donc on a été récompensé
puisque le collage a remporté le premier
prix catégorie façade donc c'est ça
vraiment qui a donné l'impulsion l'année
dernière ce concours qui a donné
l'impulsion l'année dernière et
ce qui explique qui est beaucoup
d'élèves impliqués cette année des
élèves ravis donc de planter arroser
surtout de mieux comprendre la
biodiversité de leur île désormais les
plantes n'ont plus aucun secret pour ses
petits collégiens qui ça donne le plus
souvent possible au jardinage mais
surtout à l'élaboration des fiches
présentant chaque plante et leurs
caractéristiques
on entretient les espaces vertes on
déracine les mauvaises herbes
sensibilisons les élèves au
développement durable
nous mettons en place des actions pour
les sensibiliser nous avons recouvert
la de sable nous avons mis du gazon
puis nous avons ajouté des plantes comme
derrière nous il y a de la vanille et
tout et de la menthe et tout
et ce sont des plantes qui peut des
plantes médicinales au début il y avait
16 plantes en débits mais maintenant il
y a 25 plantes endémiques fédérer les
jeunes autour d'un projet commun mais
surtout les emmener à mieux appréhender
les plantes de La Réunion et leurs
bienfaits la référente à la matière y
trouve une richesse incomparable que la
super passée au 23 élèves de l'atelier
jardin de l'option développement durable
j'estime que les plantes médicinales
sont importantes et c'est une partie de
la culture réunionnaise qu'il faut non
seulement les découvrir mais savoir
comment les utiliser pas faire n'importe
quoi mais les utiliser dans un bon
esprit de préservation de la santé pour
le jardin créole certains élèves ne
connaissent pas ce que c'est que
un pied de manioc des patates des songes
et donc dans le jardin créole et j'ai
voulu recréer cet espace qu'on permette
aux générations futures de voir tout ce
qui était utilisé anciennement dans les
repas en prévention aussi de citer une
maladie d'obésité un retour en arrière
pour une meilleure alimentation en
montrant l'intérêt des plantes créoles
des
légumineuses etc bravo donc aux quatre
ambassadrices du collège qui ont su
présenter avec beaucoup de passions
leurs projets quand le collège devient
jardin aux membres du jury des sixième
rencontre et co-responsables l'objectif
étant de transformer le collège en un
jardin coloré avec un sentier botanique
riche d'espèces endémiques indigènes et
exotiques l'apport des plantes
médicinales a donné à ce jardin un
caractère patrimonial dont les enfants
et leur encadrants peuvent être fiers
OK